bill Orem Lakers writer for the athletic
as I mentioned most recent column Lakers
lottery pick opens up a summer of
possibilities bill the kind enough to
join us good morning bill what do you
what do you mean by the summer of
possibilities for the Lakers with that
lottery pick well there's always
possibilities with this team but I do
think that we know it strengthens any
offers they want to make for that second
superstar to pair with LeBron James
whether it's Anthony Davis or someone
else that they could go pry away from
another team it just gives them it gives
them more options than they had before
before Tuesday afternoon when they you
know they're looking at a future with
LeBron James that wants young guys and
at cap space the 11th pick is is these a
decent pick in the lottery and while
this is a probably top-heavy draft the
fourth pick obviously gives them
significantly more leverage to go in and
and try to rebuild quickly but you start
and I immediately thought once they
moved into the top four well that
certainly made it a little bit more
interesting with the package you can put
together for Anthony Davis what do you
think the the package would take to get
Anthony Davis what would that look like
it's hard to say just because you're
dealing with almost an entirely clean
slate in terms of the people who would
be making that decision it's all Magic
Johnson dealing with dealt them it's
going to be Rob pálinka dealing with
David Griffin you know and in the Lakers
package at the trade deadline was
basically everything including a season
box to the Dodgers basically it was it
was Alonso ball Brandon Ingram Kyle
Kuzma Josh Hart and and Tim first-round
pick so thanks obviously were a bit of a
mystery at the time but but now you know
that one of those the top four is a
fourth pick in the draft
I don't I don't know if it would take
all of those guys like like the Lakers
tried to put out there in February I
think that that situation was a little
too maybe a little too hot to the touch
tax I get a deal done but now obviously
David Griffin is assessing his situation
obviously his first his first priority
is trying to keen Anthony Davis in New
Orleans you don't want
any of those kind if you can avoid it
but if it does come to that start
talking about a package Brandon Ingram a
son Brandon Ingram's health is is that a
point where teams are comfortable taking
him on and I just don't know if that's
the case yet despite the positive
reports we got on his on his blood clot
at the end of the season but if you're
talking bonds up all Brandon Ingram cows
by a fourth overall pick
I mean I the Lakers can't do better than
that and you're asking teams like the
Knicks Celtics to beat that package
that's a pretty that's a pretty that's
pretty strong that's pretty strong
package that's the Lakers trading
basically their entire future for for
that second star why does Anthony Davis
want to play in Los Angeles
well I get for my client of course as
well as Ron James there is kind of that
partners up there he has been in what
the NBA's smallest market for the first
six or seven years of his career and as
great as he is he is not he has not
become you know the faint going the way
that but player if his talent might
might expect to get to that level he
also have won at the level that a player
of that caliber would would be expected
to and you would expect both of those
things to change if he can part them
with is the most powerful force in the
game and LeBron James and then the most
powerful brand in the Los Angeles Lakers
so you know it's the same reason I think
a lot of guys want to play in LA Erie it
it hasn't really worked out that way
when it's come to free agency and I
think that's what I think the Lakers are
cognizant of in wanting to get a deal
done not only with whether Anthony Davis
but I'll be available and interested in
another year but well what about the
Clippers though bill what about the
Clippers get involved in this thing does
he have to if he's in Los Angeles does
he have to play with the Lakers no and I
think the Clippers you know we saw at
the trade deadline are willing to
creative to get things I think the
Clippers timeline I think the Clippers
path for a little more straightforward
than the Lakers they can go out and find
these guys then create okay these
players are interested in joining this
team if they go get you know two guys in
the summer
as crazy as it sounds they don't they
don't need Anthony Davis they have they
have it yeah right if there is if
there's a and if there is a package that
the Clippers are interested in for
pelicans are interested in Francie Davis
the Clippers have they would obviously
be interested but the problem is fewer
young assets has to be talking about
else is Alexander and then and then
other pieces around him but you know the
Clippers are like the rest of the league
like most of the week don't have the
assets to match what the Lakers that
offer in the event New Orleans does end
up shopping Anthony Davis yeah if I'm
New Orleans I I welcome that opportunity
if I if if the Lakers want to you know
tip the table up and let everything fall
off the table and it goes to New Orleans
and I'm New Orleans and I can get Kuzma
I could get Ingram health-wise if he's
okay even Lonzo ball like Josh Hart and
I get that fourth pick overall I take
that I put Zion in there and I got
Holliday and I go okay you know we at
least have the semblance of a roster
that can do some damage my big concern
and I was told this last night is by a
source that the pelicans just don't want
to have the Lakers benefit and get
Anthony Davis and I said even if that
hurts the pelicans and he said maybe and
that sounds strange to me that they
don't I know you don't want to see
Anthony Davis more times if you send him
in the West than the east but and that
seems crazy if if I can get the best
deal I take the best deal and I move on
your thoughts yeah I think that what we
thought the wait deadline it felt like
there was going to be the Lakers tax
basically where he was gonna end up with
the Lakers that was going to have to be
an even better deal and you have to get
some someone else but you're but you're
theoretically you're dealing with you
know have a clique more where it's an
additional play or an additional pick I
know
I agree with you in theory but I do
think there is kind of an an allergy
around the league to the notion of
clutch sports kind of being able to team
up their superstars in one place Queens
all the gala could fall trying to trying
to force this before the trade deadline
I think I think that this is a situation
where a lot of people would like to see
the small market team you know be able
to retain their superstar and succeed
with him and and and not let the you
know the big bad agent come in and and
and make the such and dictate terms of
the situation but ultimately I think New
Orleans when it actually comes to make a
deal it did not have that's a decision
in in February there was there was time
there still is time but when it comes
down to it you are either going to lose
this guy for nothing or you can or you
can restart like young talent I think
New Orleans is going to make whatever
the best deal correct organization is
and David Griffin is is the kind of
executive who will calm all understand
that won't do that feel good to talk to
you again we appreciate your time as
always my pleasure Dan thanks for having
me that's bill Orem Lakers writer for
the athletic the lottery luck opens up a
summer possibilities I agree for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]